[Musique]
nous sommes à l'écomusée d'alsace et
aujourd'hui jeudi c'est le jour des
bénévoles travaux d'entretien de
construction inventaire des collections
tout au programme de ces assidu du jeudi
une belle équipe qui fournit ce travail
de l'ombre indispensable à la vie du
musée puis bénévolat l'écomusée cela
depuis 1974 donc on continue les années
je suis en même temps administrateurs et
un des papas fondateur de l'écomusée en
tant que bénévole j'ai déjà mon ancien
métier qui était maître maçon d'accord
donc je m'occupais de la cre
pratiquement tous ses bâtiments passé
entre même et ensuite on organise avec
georges donc les chantiers du jeudi
puisque aujourd'hui jeudi c'est jour de
travail comme nous sommes bénévoles
monsieur plus nous donne des petits
coups pinceaux des voix des petits
bricolages préserver donner vie et
transmettre le patrimoine alsacien
demande un minutieux travail de
recherche et de conservation dans ce
grenier des milliers d'objets recueillis
par les équipes du musée
certains d'entre eux viendront décorer
quelques-uns des intérieurs traditionnel
recréer pour le musée les autres seront
conservés pour les générations futures
c'est en tout cas un véritable travail
de fourmi je suis le sauveteur de la
collection défaut les collections
d'objets du mythe de l'écomusée voilà
donc ça représente beaucoup de travail
on a énormément d'objets à recenser et
les recenser les prendre en photo faire
une fiche pour chacun les classes et
tout ça donc on est je suis beaucoup
dans les greniers dans la poussière et
les greniers on découvre toujours les
objets particuliers qu'il faut des fois
j'ai donc il faut souder fois chercher
là l'origine c'est toujours très
intéressant depuis 33 ans l'écomusée
d'alsace a fait de la préservation du
patrimoine bâti sa raison d'être
ainsi ce sont des constructions venus de
tout le territoire qui ont fait du site
un véritable petit village à l'ouverture
il y avait une vingtaine de maisons
aujourd'hui nous en avons plus de
soixante dix en comptant les annexes les
granges le lavoir etc
c'est donc devenu un véritable petit
village
dans lequel et fourmillements de vie
c'est cette une des spécificités de
l'écomusée d'alsace c'est que c'est un
musée vivant
nous y avons une soixantaine de salariés
mais aussi 250 bénévoles actifs 500
adhérents qui accueille tous les ans à
l'heure actuelle environ deux cent mille
visiteurs à l'apogée dans les années 90
nous étions même à près de quatre cent
mille visiteurs nous incarnions à
l'époque véritablement le patrimoine
bâti tel qu'il nous a été livré par des
générations d'alsaciens nous l'avons
étudié nous l'avons nous avons écrit
dessus et nous le transmettrons aux
visiteurs voilà les l'émission que
l'écomusée d'alsace a assumé pendant
trois décennies de son ouverture 84
jusque vers 2013 derrière la
préservation du patrimoine
il s'agit aussi de transmettre ces
gestes qui ont fait la vie de nos
ancêtres transmission au public bien sûr
mais aussi aux bénévoles qui pour les
plus jeunes d'entre eux n'ont pas connu
même de loin ses façons de faire qu'avec
tous les jeunes bénévoles et ben on leur
apprend comment on a fait le feu pour
faire la cuisine avec les cuisinières à
bois on cuisine à l'ancienne et en fait
ça va tout naturellement moi je vois mon
petit fils qui a huit ans le dimanche et
ne jure que par ici pour vivre comme ça
m'a mis mon ma maman vivait du moment
qu'on passe la passion la passion elle
passe à tout âge autre challenge relevé
par les équipes du musée rendre à la
nature la vitalité et la diversité
qu'elle avait dans l'alsace rurale du
19e siècle une gageur quand on sait ce
qui était ce site jusqu'à l'arrivée du
musée
il faut savoir qu'il ya 30 ans c'était
ici un espace complètement désert et
avec les efforts qui ont été faits par
l'équipe qui a installé l'écomusée le
paysage totalement changé la nature a
repris ses droits mais les oiseaux sont
venus les plantes
aquatique des plans de toi que toutes
les plantes en général se sont
réinstallées et aujourd'hui on a un
milieu tout à fait vert est très
agréable ici nous sommes un musée de
plein air
ici nous sommes à l'air libre et la
nature et la biodiversité les animaux le
végétal font partie de nos collections
l'environnement lui-même fait partie de
nos collections puisque nous avons la
chance d'avoir une extraordinaire
biodiversité
enfin notre village ne serait pas
complet sans ces animaux de ferme veaux
vaches cochons sont ici des acteurs à
part entière
tout comme ses vignes qui font partie
des 4,5 hectares de terres mises en
culture pour transmettre les méthodes de
l'agriculture d'antan
un théâtre naturel qui se fait au rythme
des saisons
alors là je suis en train de palis et la
vigne donc pour la vie nous avons un
desserrement qui sont en train de tomber
et on les accroche pour pas qu'ils
cassent et pour avoir une meilleure
récolte
je travaille ici à l'écomusée il fit
salariés en tant que médiatrice agricole
nous nous occupons des animaux deschamps
et nous faisons des médiations des
animations devant les visiteurs par
exemple on fait la traite de la vache
devant les visiteurs en leur expliquant
que ce que l'on fait pourquoi on le fait
on amène ensuite le lait pour qu'il soit
transformé
on fera aussi les cochons pour la glande
et quand on faisait à l'époque et
d'autres animations mais devant devant
les visiteurs avec les animaux nous
trouvons dans ce site un centre
pédagogique de d'éducation à la nature
comme nous en avance sur l'ensemble du
département c'est une spécificité haut
rhinoise puisse tout d'abord un peu plus
d'une demi douzaine de le centre
d'initiation à la nature en plein en
montagne et ce centre là fonctionne très
bien et les classes de l'ensemble du
secteur à voir l'ensemble du département
bien six rondes ici pour être
sensibilisés à la nature depuis 2014
l'émission de l'écomusée sont en
évolution lieu de préservation et de
transmission le site se fait aujourd'hui
laboratoire objectif
interrogé le passé pour construire le
futur à l'heure du développement durable
et de la coop 21 quelques-unes des
solutions à la crise écologique pourrait
bien s'inventer ici c'est un joyau
d'autant plus que c'est un joyau
non c'est un vraiment amusé sociétal un
musée vivant qui est tourné vers
l'avenir donc qui permet de transmettre
le passé à toutes les générations mais
qui est tourné vers l'avenir donc l'idée
c'est de redonner du sens à ce
patrimoine aujourd'hui alors comment
comment est bien en créant par exemple
un festival d'expérimentation
constructive qui va démarrer en juin
2010 est juste à côté de moi ici
nous avons invité un certain nombre
d'architectes à créer des projets qui de
construction qui sont des constructions
du 21e siècle mais qui sont aussi en
dialogue avec le patrimoine
donc c'est quelque part il s'agit de
renouer avec le fil de l'histoire
peut-on construire une maison alsacienne
du 21e siècle
ainsi ce sont trois nouvelles
constructions qui verront le jour de
juin à juillet dans le cadre du festival
boynton certains chantiers seront
ouverts au public si vous êtes bricoleur
ou simplement curieux tous les
renseignements sont à prendre auprès de
l'écomusée